-You were in business
for a long time
before you were in television.
What is your take, you know,
coming from
the world of finance,
is this idea of Trump
is a great businessman,
is it a mirage or is there
something to the idea
that he was good at this other
thing before he was President?
-Well, if you were to compare
him to Mitt Romney,
when Mitt Romney ran,
all of his peers
in private equity backed him.
When President Trump ran,
you didn't see anyone from
the big real-estate universe.
You didn't see any big New York
business people back him.
You saw people in middle America
who wanted a change.
And the thing is
he did a brilliant thing
in that he went to see them.
Those rallies were in places
where I haven't visited.
I don't know if you visited.
And it gave people hope.
The twisted thing is
he gave them hope
without an actual resolution.
He had the smarts to say,
"I'm gonna solve
income inequality,"
but he's not doing it.
When he says,
"I'm gonna go after trade,"
that's a good idea.
There are issues. China?
Yeah, there's problems there,
but what he's actually doing
makes no sense.
If he said,
"Intellectual property
or artificial intelligence,
we're gonna go after that."
President Trump, if you asked
him about A.I., no joke,
he would think
it was a steak sauce.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So what he's offering
the American people --
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's a brilliant marketer
with no real solutions,
and the country needs solutions.
-You know, he falls back
on the economy every time
it seems like he's cornered.
Is there anything missing
because like you said,
consumer confidence is up, you
know, business confidence is up.
Is there an argument to be made
that he's making a fair point
when he says,
"Hey, despite everything
and despite how it's a circus
at the White House,
the economy is good,"
or is there something
that he's leaving out there?
-Well, there's something
to remember.
The economy was good before
President Trump took office.
It was a slow and steady climb
out of the financial crisis.
What Obama didn't do was sell it
very well.
He's a -- somewhat of a,
not a soft-spoken guy,
but certainly more humble
than Trump.
Everyone is.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And when Trump says
things are great
and it's trickling down,
it's not.
We have lots of people with
jobs, and that's great,
but they just don't pay
enough money.
And so this idea that things are
going to trickle-down,
if you look at Republicans
that are running for office now
in the midterms,
they don't talk about
the economy
because they know,
in their states,
people aren't living
comfortably.
It's those who don't
need to run again.
They're saying, "Look at
this economy. It's great."
It's great for big business.
Right after Trump won --
I don't know if you remember --
he snuck out of Trump Tower and
he went to the 21 Club, right?
One of the fanciest restaurants
in New York.
Lots of people love it.
Filled with wealthy people,
and he said,
"I'm gonna lower your taxes."
And he did.
So President Trump
wanted to impress
and do this
for the wealthiest people
and he has done that.
The concern is that people
who voted for change
aren't going to get that change.
-I showed one of your greatest
hits, and again,
I'm a fan of your work,
but I do --
I think it's only fair
to show, really,
one of the flubs of the year.
I have to tell you, I loved it.
We were really happy
when you did it.
-I'm glad you were.
My kids were too. My kids were.
-This I will say, if your mom
was on TV and you were a kid,
you'd be very happy about this.
So here you are not as sharp as
you were earlier.
Let's take a look.
-As California is farting --
excuse me -- fighting,
the largest wildfire
in the state's history...
[ Laughter ]
-They're farting.
-Well, there are a lot of vegans
in California.
-That's true.
[ Laughter ]
-There are a lot of cleanses
that go on.
So they could be farting.
-They're farting the wildfires.
-They could be farting.
Listen, I did not get into
television until I was 36.
So if you wanted a TV presenter
who is a teleprompter superstar
with perfect posture
and all of those things,
then you picked the wrong girl.
-No, I want, you know,
once a year
someone who accidentally
says farting.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
We're gonna keep it real,
and you know, farting happens.
-It does happen. Thanks
so much for being here.